good afternoon I'm Matthew Spalding
associate vice president and Dean for
Hillsdale College here in Washington DC
and welcome to the allen p kirby center
for constitutional studies and
citizenship an important aspect of
learning about the Constitution which we
emphasize at Hillsdale is to know
something about American political
history both in terms of seeing models
for application of ideas but because
they're often lessons in American
politics that can be applied today much
of American politics on both the left
and the right is about how ideas in
movements interact with politics and
especially political parties what we are
seeing today with the incoming new
speaker is in many ways an aspect of
that and the effect of it over time
indeed of late both political parties
have been affected by populists elements
hotlist movements in populist candidates
is that past prologue I'm very happy to
have a guest in print good friend of
ours to come and talk about that subject
much about the topic to formally
introduce our speaker one of our
students our current currently on the
whip program and a faff will speak to us
she's a senior studying American Studies
at Hillsdale College she's currently
interning at the American principles
project she's a member of the chai Omega
sorority and is also a member of the
nationally ranked Hillsdale College
shotgun team
thank you dr. Spaulding Henry Olson is a
senior fellow at the ethics and Public
Policy Center where his research focuses
on the electoral channel challenges
facing modern American conservatism in
particular mr. Olson studies election
returns and pull data to understand why
people vote the way they do and how
conservative politicians in advance
their ideas in current political climate
mr. Olson previously served as a vice
president and director of the American
Enterprise Institute national research
initiative a vice president at the
Manhattan Institute and president of the
Commonwealth foundation he has published
in The Wall Street Journal the
Washington Post Weekly Standard and is
the co-author with Dante Scala of the
forthcoming the four phases of the
Republican Party the fight for the 2016
presidential nomination in tandem with
his new book Olson is currently blogging
for national review online at 2016 the
gops four phases you received his BA
from Claremont McKenna College and his
JD from the University of Chicago Law
School please join me in welcoming mr.
Henry Olson
thank you Anna and thank you matthew her
it's regen you only an honor to be asked
to talk in this hole surrounded by so
many founders whose images I'm unworthy
to live up to but such as the challenge
of working or speaking at Hillsdale one
is always surrounded by the promise and
the opportunity to live up to the ideal
set by our American founders my talk
today is about populism past and
prologue but populism is not something
that is thought of very positively today
in fact for many it is a specter and we
know that Spectre is the title of the
next James Bond movie but for most
people populism is a specter that haunts
and frights frightens and particularly
the American elites are frightened by
the specter of populism that they see
rising throughout our country today in
fact I would say that if there's any one
word beyond perhaps not see or communist
that is a negative attribution in
American politics it is the word
populism if or populist if there is
anything an educated person is taught it
is that populism is irrational angry
often bigoted or racist and that to be a
populist in the American political
tradition say in the akin of the
populist party of the 1890s is to be
beyond the pale of reasonable discourse
if despite this Universal elite
condemnation the three most energetic
political movements today progressivism
Tea Party ism and what I will call
trumpism are all of distinct populist
elements they're all animated energized
by things that are classically populous
in the American vein if every person who
said they were supporter of one of these
three movements instead of being divided
were united and were to stand on one
side of this room nearly half of
Americans would be populous so if half
of americans are populists then one of
two things must be true either the
classically few of populism is correct
and American politics is crashing down
around
in fact one sees this sense in much
media commentary about the current
political circumstance or another thing
might be true populism is not toxic to
America the first may be true and we'll
get to that later in my lecture but I
think the second is undoubtedly true
that while classical populism of the
sort that has brought us throughout
history the Greek tyrants which
Aristotle and Plato wrote about which
produced in our modern times Lenin and
Hitler and perón and Hugo Chavez is
toxic American populism is in fact not
only not toxic it is essential to the
glue that holds American democracy and
human passion together that what it does
American populism has distinct elements
that channel human passions something in
erotical to the goals of the founding
and in fact make human Liberty possible
in a democratic environment so today's
lecture I'm going to try and discuss and
address three different things I'm going
to try and show what I just argued that
all enduring American political
coalition's are in fact classically
American populace in their origin and
that secondly today's populist movements
are in fact merely modern variations of
the same theme which is to say they are
not toxic to the American political
discourse no matter what one might read
in the Wall Street Journal in the New
York time but third that none is
currently constituted is prepared to
become an enduring Coalition in America
precisely because one of the elements of
American populism a positive agenda that
actually addresses the root cause that
said enforce the populace demand for
populists elements is not met by any of
them none of them have a positive agenda
that directly relates to the problems
that are giving rise to the populace
feel in our time we first start with the
first argument is probably the most
contentious among political theorists or
political scientist and if I were one I
would have to write a book or two or
three to respond or maybe many articles
depends where I'm in the tenure process
I think if you
throughout American politics political
history one would find that there are
four elements of American populism then
elements that I call the dispossession
the creation of the other the reconquest
and the agenda let me go into each of
those and what I mean by those by the
dispossession I mean that the first
element is that a large mass of American
people feel that they have been wrongly
prevented or wrongly held back from
their ability to pursue their own having
this is perhaps the central theme of
American political life Americans are
united by the belief that through their
own efforts and with the assistance of a
democratically elected government they
can if properly enable pursue their own
happiness whether that is in material
terms or religious terms or in some
other term or usually some combination
of them the populace moment comes when a
large mass and perhaps a majority feel
that they have been wrongly dispossessed
of their ability to pursue their
birthright of matter the creation of the
other is the second element once one has
feels that they are dispossessed the
movement the grouping comes to believe
that that dispossession is the cause of
a other that has controlled American
government that other can be economic as
it was in many aspects of our American
history it can be political as it was
during the Reagan era which I'll make
that argument momentarily it can be
socio-political much as Lincoln's
argument about southern aristocrats and
their northern allies what they called
oh face it was but in the sense is that
a other that is alien that no longer
believes in American principles has
taken control of the government and has
thereby caused the dispossession the
reconquest well that's pretty obvious
but one and two together and the
solution is when the people rule as
Andrew Jackson said in 1832 and is often
said restore the rule of the people
remove the rule of the other and the
American Dream can continue
this is in fact been the central element
of every one of our political coalition
in the agenda is the actual serious set
of policies that connects the moral
sense of dispossession to the action of
what we will do when we recall and the
agenda is always something that involves
the recreation of the individuals
ability to pursue happiness on their own
it is never a Peronist agenda it is
never a Hitlerian agenda it is never a
state dominating agenda it is always one
that whether or not it ends up in fact
to be that way and that's a question
about the New Deal that i'll address it
is always both understood by the public
and couch to the public in terms of the
recovery of the right to pursue
happiness on your so let's go through
American history and see whether or not
those four elements are in fact present
in what most political scientists would
say are the reigning coalition we often
hear about realigning election and what
a realigning election does is it
installs one set of political actors who
more or less full dominance way over the
national government for a period of 30
to 40 years most political observers
have said that we've had a realigning
election in 1800 when Jefferson
dispossessed the Federalists and
Jeffersonian democracy rule for the next
20 so you in 1832 when Jackson recreated
and reformed the Jeffersonian coalition
to basically rule until the onset of the
Civil War 1860 when Abraham Lincoln
recreated in with the aid of many others
the Republican Party and applied what I
would argue Jack classic Jefferson
jacksonian populist elements to
dispossess the Death Zone Ian's
themselves from rule 1932 when roosevelt
created the New Deal coalition and I
would argue 1980 was in fact a
realigning election although not one
exactly or classically is understood by
political scientists because the
dominance a while to exert itself IE
publicans did not take control of the
national government until much later in
the process but dominated the ideas
under which all
political coalition's operated through
out that error for the Jeffersonian the
dispossession occurred in the during the
reign of Adam the alien and sedition
acts which basically criminalized
political criticism and the Hamiltonian
economics that they pursued were
considered by jefferson and madison and
what they called them the republicans or
what we now know is the Democratic
Republicans as being in a FEMA to the
Republican ideals and principle they
created the idea of the other the other
was the wealthy usually New England
merchant who were trying to reinstitute
rule of English principles under
American phones in fact the election of
1800 was perhaps the most vicious
rhetorically that we've ever had in this
country Jefferson himself as
intellectually able as he was was not
above calling his opponents Anglo men
and mana Kratz and alleging that they
wanted to abolish the Constitution the
1800 election was close but it resulted
in victory a victory which was then
reaffirmed in every single election for
the next 24 years and the agenda was
simple it was not to take the property
of the people was not to as was done
with the Tories who supported the king
drive them out of the country which is
what a classic populist movement might
do instead it was to repeal the
offending acts and to recover the
American sense of citizenship
Jefferson's first inaugural included the
famous phrase we are all Republicans we
are all Federalist which is to say yes
we disagree with you yes we think that
you want to do on the Constitution but
you have rights too you are Americans we
will simply repeal remove your rule
which prevented people from pursuing
happiness and then we will go on with
the constitutional the second realigning
election was Jackson and he followed the
classic principles only simply adapted
to the issues of the day instead of the
Alien and Sedition Acts the question was
the National Bank of America whose
Charter was coming up for renewal this
is something is kind of like a super
federal reserve but in many ways even
more pernicious than what a polite might
call a federal reserve
rather than simply control the money
supply it actually made investments in
underwrote private bank those almost as
if it was intended i believe by hamilton
to be the under girder of a national
industrial policy what we would call it
today and the people who are allowed
with the bank also wanted to use federal
tax dollars to have internal
improvements canals and railroads to pay
for industrial expansion Jackson and the
Democrats argued this was wrong this was
setting the rule of the rich over the
rule of the people who's creating what
we would now call crony capitalism and
they've created the other the New York
banker the New England merchant the
Philadelphia lawyer the people who were
in fact the ones who were moving for
these systems and who would financially
benefit for these nobody can ever write
a better critique of crony capitalism
and andrew jackson road from his veto
message of the National Bank detailing
exactly who would benefit and how they
would benefit financially from this and
arguing that the American birthright
meant that this could not stand the
American people agreed with him 1832 he
won the bank was killed and except
during errors of economic unrest f state
of the panic of 1837 Kratz ruled the
national government almost interrupted
Lee in fact by 1854 the main political
party that supported this the Whigs had
died the agenda again was not positive
in the sense of it was not a
confiscatory agenda it was not one that
drove these people out of the body
politic it was not classically populace
it was American populace it removed the
barriers and said now we will get on
with our lives Lincoln and by 1860
obviously we had a question with slavery
a small squabble over peculiar
institution I jest of course this is
something that in Lincoln sperms was not
simply a moral abomination and a wrong
not simply opposed to our principal of a
free nation but one that was directly at
directly threaten the ability of free
labor and freemen to pursue their own
happiness is how
divided speech in fact argued that there
was a conscious conspiracy between the
past president the sitting president his
opponent Stephen Douglas in the Supreme
Court Chief Justice Roger 20 not to
prevent the extirpation of slavery in
the South but to extend slavery to the
North that the principles of the Dred
Scott decision could not be limited to
the existence of slavery in the South
they had to extend to the north and that
meant that your ability as an American
to pursue happiness was directly rap
other was obvious the southern slave
holder and the northern doughface again
though the agenda was one that was in
fact non confiscatory in its original
returns lincoln did not and the
republican platform did not want to take
slaves and drive southerners out of the
body politic they wanted to pay for the
emancipation of slaves only the event of
the Civil War changed that and the other
aspects of the republican economic
agenda a land-grant college act spread
knowledge of agricultural technique the
Pacific Railroad act that underwrote the
creation of a Transcontinental Railroad
the Homestead Act that gave free land to
people to move into the new territory
for all design to give people in the
modern age tools by which they could
pursue happy that was how it was sold
that was how is understood and the
Lincoln coalition ruled for roughly
seventy two years with only a couple of
interruption then of course the Great
Depression horizon obviously that
created political pressures Roosevelt
responded by again arguing that you have
been dispossessed by a system of Charis
and greedy industrialists who have
displaced the American Founding and
placed their rule of property over your
ability to pursue happy he calls his
foes economic royalists he called the
industrialists unscrupulous money
changers of the temple invoking both
biblical and secular imagery to rally
people whose cause they were the other
and the victory was almost complete by
1936 Republicans had been reduced to
fewer than fifteen percent of the
members of the House of Representatives
the smallest percentage than any major
has ever held in the House of
Representatives again though one can
argue what the New Deal actually did or
whether it was something that had seeds
of its own destruction built within it
but it was both sold to the American
people initially constructed in a way to
allow people to move in a modern
industrial age to help themselves the
Wagner Act for example which required
labor union bargaining was an imposition
and a violation of comp of American
constitutional tradition but it was
nowhere near as extremist things that
Social Democrats did to basically allow
unions to set wages themselves it was
meant to level the playing field and in
fact American unions have always even at
their day they had less power than
unions and moreover at least social
democratic country the same is true of
Social Security unlike many other social
democratic countries that basically made
the creation of a guaranteed national
minimum income the added of the
requirement of their city of their state
Social Security prevented people from
falling into deprivation but allowed
them to rock it was let more of a what
we call a safety net than a hannah again
we can argue whether or not the New Deal
in fact had seeds of its own destruction
or seeds that were contrary to that but
it was both crucially unsold as and
understood by the American people as
being simply new means to achieve
traditional end and then we step into
Ronald ray Ronald Reagan angers the left
precisely because in political modern
history he is the first leader who takes
the classical populist elements and
turns them towards conservative
traditionalist constitutional and for
him the 70s the collapse of the economy
the collapse of the sense of American
exceptionalism the fear of conquest by
Soviet Communism is what drove was with
forces that drove the demand for him the
other in his case was something unusual
in American history but simply a new
adaptation of old and the bureaucrat how
many times did Ronald Reagan rail
against central government control
bureaucratic control that was taking
away your ability to pursue happiness
substituting central government dictate
what he essentially did was removed was
keep the same template but replaced the
industrialist with the bureaucrat as the
person who was building that American
thriving and pursuing their birthright
to pursue happiness again 1980 is the
election that is is key after nineteen
eighty and the subsequent victories in
Congress everyone even Democrats must
work on Reagan istic oh that was the
point of the new democratic movement
that was the point of how Clinton was
left was that he was not an old Democrat
who opposed Reaganism he was a new
democrat who sought to modify Reaganism
but not repeal it and what were the
agenda items deregulation rearmament tax
cuts they were not ideological crusade
there were many who were disappointed
that Social Security was not
significantly repealed or rich or
reformed today there are still people
who look back and say our government
grew under Ronald Reagan as a size of
the economy shrunk is a regulatory
matter but as a size of the economy
group what would Reagan accomplish but
again the agenda meant the time the
agenda solved the problems which gave
rise to the demand for the populist
moment so all of these coalition's share
the same elements and can be understood
as using these elements that classically
ta's human passions fears and hopes and
beliefs of others and non others that of
the of the in and the out and ties it to
human Liberty as opposed to what other
regimes who don't have this structure
and don't have our political
understanding dude which is allow those
passions to destroy the regime and
establish some form of tyranny or to
each of these movements that we see
today are employing the same technique
Bernie Sanders it's pretty obvious he's
trying to recreate Roosevelt ISM in our
times only instead of having the sort of
self-help measures that the New Deal
he's explicitly saying that the problem
of America is that we have economic
decline it's being caused by the greedy
bankers and financiers if
people take over we will we do this and
we will do it by making ourselves up
like Denmark there I would argue there
are those are three of the classical
elements but that the policy solution
ultimately falls flat because what it
does is it replaces a European sense of
the role of the citizen with the state
or the American one it does not speak as
much in terms of the American ability to
pursue happiness as it does installing
the government's ability and to ensure
that no person falls below and everyone
has some form addict it replaces a
people-centric pursuit of happiness with
a state centric receive fabula for this
reason that I think that Sanders
progressivism will ultimately not form a
stable political coalition I think we've
seen elements and proof of that in the
form of which Barack Obama has pursued
this he is definitely not pursued in his
forthright a manner or as direct a
manner as Sanders hence the cause in the
democratic party for his challenge but
nevertheless through Obamacare through
dodd-frank through his attempts to bring
about climate change regulation and
other elements of the government he is
trying to create a sigh dia that
Americans need to be directed by the
government in their pursuit of happiness
as opposed to allowing the pursuit of
happiness be determined primarily
outside of public and collective
decision this is the source of why the
Republicans won in 2010 this is why the
Republicans won in 2014 and it remains
the classic billet sense of why
Republicans can win is because Americans
even today do not want that they do not
want a state directed government they do
not want a state directed society they
may want and do one many things that
many people in this room a considered to
be unconstitutional but they do not want
what progressives tell them they want
and they will react and have reacted at
the ballot box every time it becomes
clear that that is what the agenda is
since the New Deal in 1932 the second
sort that we have is Trump centrism and
Trump's
centrosome again rises from the sense of
economic stagnation declining wages his
other is immigrants and people who are
in the government business alliance
that's conspiring to send jobs overseas
so his solution is throw out the
immigrants install a wall and
renegotiate trade agreement that's his
positive agenda that ostensibly has more
in common with the Republican small our
sentiment of the American political
tradition because it says if we do this
you can pursue your own happiness but a
part of this is a is a caddy ism that a
sense that only the strong man can
reduce this the man the nose the art of
the deal this is constantly Trump's
position that only by investing
basically all power in me can you be
able to pursue your happiness there's an
inherent contradiction boat and there's
also the question in our American
political addition whether or not
classic Corona ism which is a more
socialist version of what Trump is
proposing is in fact possible in
America's but in American politics I
don't think Trump ultimately will become
the nominee but even if he were elected
president I don't think that his
coalition would last because it's
basically at odds with the American
political issue and the economics that
he proposes won't work that a short-term
gain would produce the long-term decline
if you built a wall and forced American
industry to come back home that is the
Peronist Argentine solution that is one
that ultimately will put American at
force for decline and you cannot produce
the short-term gains that he says higher
wages and more jobs for low-skilled
people without having that sort of
bought ARCIC economic regime the agenda
does not mesh with our political issue
it does not address the problem of our
time so then what about tea party ism I
think there
the tea party ism again has arises from
a similar sense only again following
Reagan fashion the sense of economic
decline in stagnation is blamed by the
Obama presidency that the Obama
presidency has raised taxes increased
regulation has increased the size of
government that's the cause of our
problem but we need to do is in some way
deal with the undoing of Obama ism where
I think and in that sense it's
classically American where I think tea
party ism failed is the lack of a
serious agenda to actually address the
problem which is to say what part aside
from Obamacare of Obama ISM is really to
blame you know it's not like economic
stagnation didn't exist for millions of
people during the bush years either many
people disability roles skyrocketed
during the bush growth years people sunk
into dependency at the lower ends of the
economic spectrum during growing years
under Republican control there's no real
sense among the tea party political
agenda that addresses those very real
question so one example of I think the
unreality of the agenda is Cruz's tax
plan that he released yesterday I looked
that up before I came and he proposes
eliminating the payroll tax you know
that's seven point six five percent that
you and your employer pay for Social
Security and Medicare and replacing all
personal income taxes with a ten percent
flat pack and he has certain deductions
and he exempts the first thirty six
thousand dollars of income from every
family and he blithely asserts that this
will produce as much revenue as was
raised before there's no possible way
that can be true there is no possible
way that can be true the amount of
revenue that those the taxes he proposes
to reform or eliminate equals nearly
eighty percent of the government's
budget a ten percent flat packs at bass
will raise half of that so your solution
is either borrow money in the next
decade while the economy allegedly grows
because of this new regime to make the
deficit under the Obama administration
look like small castles in the same or
your solution is to basically cut the
size the federal government by
thirty-five percent in one year to bring
the deficit down to acceptable level
this is not a serious plan there's no
demand to cut the federal government by
thirty-five percent one year and there's
no will to make the deficit be 1.8
trillion dollars a year as far as the
eye can see this is not a serious
platform and as such it cannot even if
elected produce the enduring coalition
that the Tea Party as expressed by Ted
Cruz once the main problem we have today
is what i call the problem of the ins
versus the outs and it's one that is
spreading throughout the Western world
and it's a direct result of the promise
and the beauty of capital that what
we've seen since the fall of the Berlin
Wall is the opening of more people to
the Western democratic liberal
capitalistic system and has ever been
seen before between 1989 and 1994 when
after aside between India liberalizing
its economy to be open to foreign trade
between the Tigers of East Asia being
open to foreign trade between China
being open to foreign trade Eastern
Europe being open to foreign trade and
then Mexico over three billion people
were added to the global Western
democratic economy at the time the total
population of the developed world was
900 million we tripled the labor force
in five year and what has been the
result of that the result of that since
that time has been the eradication of
poverty in much of the third world the
only places where we have huge numbers
of extreme poverty as defined UN and
organizations remains in those countries
whose political systems remain closed to
Western investment mainly in Africa but
in some other countries as well Western
liberal democratic capitalism has
brought more personal freedom more
personal comfort and more personal
dignity to more people in the last 25
years and has been accomplished
throughout human history this has not
come without off as we bring people
the bloody were forced they necessarily
come into competition with people who
are already in the labor force and those
of us are not in competition very much
yet but the person who dropped out of
high school with the person who only has
a high school degree weather there in
Sweden or whether they are in Sandusky
are incompetent and in the world of a
welfare state that means that it becomes
economically viable for them to have
sent themselves from the labor for not
happening in Europe where it's an
explicit policy and is happening here
where it's an implicit policy that's
what's driving the demand for populist
movements in Europe that's what's
driving the demand for populist
movements in America populism in Europe
is different I'm not going to deal with
that in this lecture but in this country
the populist movement is as it always is
the belief that Americans if only the
government were on their side would be
able to pursue happiness that is what
underlies all three of the populism
today and when we address the real
problem which is not to cut off Liberal
Democratic international capitalism but
rather as was done at the beginning of
the 20th century to accommodate our
political order so that all people can
share in some measure and not be
dispossessed by these developments then
we will have an enduring political
coalition an enduring political
coalition that secures liberties cures
growth secures the right to pursue
happiness for americans while saving
billions of people overseas and that is
the promise of american populism that is
what all three movements are trying
desperately to grasp boards and the
first one that gets there will probably
be on the right but the first one that
gets there will be the next dominant
coalition will have the next realigning
election and will define the course of
the next American Century
since I'm judge jury and executioner I
have the watch I have 22 minutes untold
until map tells me I need to cut time so
I'll take your questions we I've said
nothing provocative so I understand why
does nobody yes
oddly detached themselves from the
concerns really of the normal American
person or everyday person it's a
different way and perhaps a more
complete way of talking about what I'm
trying to get at which is that there's a
sense more and more that there is an
other that is dis associated with the
mass and people are interpreting it
differently but yes i would say that
thing that unites all populism is the
sense that the people who are running
things and they differ as to who those
people are but there's a united sense
the people who are you running things no
longer care about them no longer
understand them and no longer care to
understand them yeah you want have a
follow-up and then I'll turn it over
um I think we have seen we're seeing
worldwide a sense there is a sense I
study elections all over the world and
if I were to plot myself down in the
most educated and richest district in
England which is the cities of
Westminster the capital of London I
would find attitudes that are
internationalist and contemptuous of the
average person in non nationalist that
are every bit as strong as I would find
in the Harvard campus or in the
boardrooms of Wall Street I would find
this in Stockholm I would find this in
the palace Ely say I would find this
everywhere there is a global in and
introduced the global out in the sense
of nationalism and the sense of the
dignity of the individual is something
that is being felt as being undermined
everywhere yes sir can you wait for the
microphone I didn't realize the first
but they have a microphone coming around
thank you yeah so you said that a sort
of in the American character there's
this there's this sense of that is it's
individuals as opposed to the state and
that do you think that that is a fixed
factor of the American character because
it seems to me that on the American Left
there's there are more and more people
that are do have a more European sense
of of their place and so I think there
probably is still a majority of
Americans that see it that way whether
they're right or left but is that
changing a wool or could that change oh
I think it could change it has endured
over two hundred and something years and
it is primarily the source of why we've
never had a socialist or communist or an
openly Marxist party in America's
there's simply not enough for tile soil
I think it's quite clear that elements
of the left have gained popular support
and that there's probably more people
today than there were 30 years ago or 60
years ago who openly would time for more
state-directed but I don't think there's
anything that suggests that that's
anywhere near a majority yet the
electoral problem conservatives often
face is lumping together as the as the
other the people who seek to
take what I will call the popular New
Deal and see that as a legitimate
expression of Americanism and lump them
together with people who openly are
contemptuous of American principle
divide those two sources of people and
there's an enduring center-right
majority lump them together as has been
want too often in the last 40 years and
you create a near majority for the
opposition that does not that
continually has fissures and when the
left runs that you see people in the
center left move away and be open to
voting for the center right but if you
lump those two together there is a near
majority but it's not something that's
in their hearts it's something that's
forced upon them by the political
construct that we are creating for them
yes um dr. Spalding Thank You Henry
could could you talk a little bit about
how both in the past and currently you
perceive it occurring one of the key
aspects of this that you imply but in
touch on as much is how the populace
sentiment is incorporated into the party
system yeah it's no coincidence that the
critical elections you mentioned all
became actively in control of one of the
political parties where as opposed to
say William Jennings Bryan never quite
took hold right so that that aspect of
becoming part and parcel of a major
political party is an important aspect
of how in the current day do you see
that occurring is that a problem how
does it interact with the political
party system I think what we're seeing
today is the temps by these people to
retake control of the political parties
that both yes if you were to ask if you
were to sit down and put people from the
center American Progress and people from
freedom works in the same they were both
argue that the leaders of their party
are too much in control by elites who
don't care about what the average person
that they're trying to do is restore
popular control over their particular
political party we have a unique
opportunity to do that through the
primary system here that essentially our
open primary system is unique in a
mirror
it allows hostile takeovers of political
parties by people I I don't think the
problem is one of I think the problem
why it does not happen as we have not
yet found a political movement and a
political discourse that is both
persuasive enough and broad-based enough
to allow for those political for those
political victories to be in to be the
sort of regular sort of political
victories that reduce coalition in other
words it's not the our current problem
is not one of a fall of structure but
it's a short coming of statesmanship for
by the people who for to be trying to
persuade that answer your question
it needs to be both the populist
movements need to be both mature in the
manner in which they pursue political
power and once they pursue political
power it needs to be done in a way that
the people who they have in some way
dispossession reconcile themselves that
this is what Ronald Reagan classically
then which was that in mobilizing
popular conservatism to retake the
Republican Party he did it on terms that
allowed the reconciliation with the
elite elements of the Republican Party
unlike Barry Goldwater who openly tried
to repudiate them and consequently when
you're told that you're not welcome at
the party you try and hold on to your
party the elites and the Republican
Party accommodated themselves to
Reaganism precisely because of the
statesmanship of the leader of
conservative Bob bring so many questions
up I agree I'll start with where you
ended with Reagan because I would say
what Reagan did was create a new elite I
did not turn American eek he created a
new elite a new conservative elite you
did not turn you know the White House
over to Andrew Jackson's hillbilly shall
I say but I'm glad bat well first
question is the failure of the three
movements right now is that a failure of
a populism itself or is that a failure
of the program that is not catching on
with the public i would say that
populism has failed to a large degree
because both class struggle class envy
and vengeance have not part of the
american way to settle scores with the
three you examined there were safety
valves I mean Jefferson did by half the
country so he inflated his electorate
had lots of land to give out and they
all became Democratic Republican states
what everyone says about Jackson the
motivation were that Indian Removal Act
was rewarding Georgia farmers with land
that was available so there was a safety
valve and of course with FDR you do it
through the income tax now all you've
said so far was about the economic side
I'm glad you mentioned Brian requests
the election of 89
sex is extremely interesting you had
lots of others it starts with the big
bad bankers in Wall Street you read the
popular suppress you see lots of
reference to Jewish bankers
international conspiracies and bankers
have no country and all that which leads
to the revival of the KKK which they
never talked about Brian 18-24 loved the
KKK sameera the Scopes trial where
they're trying to deal with them get
Darwin out of the schools and we're back
to that to some degree an
anti-immigration anti legal immigration
respective part is Allah so Democrats
love to grab the Brian part of the
redistribution aspect Roosevelt had
Brian's family to the family with white
house to say here is your grandfather's
program I've enacted at all but of
course you didn't mention these nasty
size of it so I guess my question is is
it the failure of populism worth the
failure of these three groups or the
failure of the American people if you
want the American character to an
embrace class struggle class Envy and
vengeance as a policy I don't think
populism is in the jew crew this is why
the solution of the positive agenda that
is consistent with american aspirations
is crucial to the success of a populist
movement i recall i didn't mention 1896
i didn't mention nineteen eighty ninety
six because there's only so much time
and that actually requires a lot more
but that was an attempted populist
moment that failed and i think it was an
attempted populist moment and failed
that largely failed precisely because
the agenda that he advanced including
government ownership of railroads the
government ownership of a telegraph was
something that threatened the idea of
americans self-determination so what
mckinley was able to do was recreate the
lincoln coalition for his time and
basically replacing the homestead Air
with you know the homestead ad and the
railroad with the terror that this is
how within the high industrial tariffs
we will give you quote unquote a full
dinner pail your security and ability to
advance is met by our agenda not by
their radical agenda and that is one
fact why
Ryan populism failed and why McKinley
was able to reconstruct Lincoln populism
for the early industrial age with
respect to the current element I think
you put your nail on the head and why I
think none of the current populism
currently on hand can address the
question which is to say that we may
need to reconcile ourselves to the idea
that widely spread purely private sector
growth for people without education is
not coming in the next 30 the Trump and
the crews form of populism basically
assumed that cruise through his through
the reduction in government that's
something that we will see this
restoration of not only add a not only
numerically hot bro what Jeb Bush likes
to say four percent rather than 2% well
I will say on this week of st. Crispin's
day I don't think anyone ever goes into
the bloody reach for four percent growth
but the assumption is get this out of
the way and everything that we've
experienced from the post-war era will
bring up the Bushehr it wasn't there in
the bush era it may not be coming back
and Trump the same thing give me I'll do
I'll do a better trade deal I'll kick
these people who were company basically
he's arguing that the problem is
competition you're being you're being
unfairly competed against by foreigners
living here immigrants and living abroad
free trade I'll deal with the unfair
competition and growth will come back
but that may not be true either which of
the extent that is true would be true
only in the short term by adopting a
naught Arctic mercantilist Peronist
economy which would produce a short-term
gain and long-term debt and then you've
got Sanders ISM which basically says our
solution is redistribution but the
problem is income the problem is not
opportunity none of these deal with the
mixture of the need to secure some form
of recent stand share of the wealth so
people who are citizens feel part of the
citizen project with the America
can need the crucial need for human
freedom that most of that come from
private enough I don't think any of the
that is the safety valve and we may not
have a safety valve because we may be in
a state where we're going to have to
adjust for the next 30 or 40 years to
three billion people becoming half as
wealthy as we are which is where China
and India and Vietnam and Malaysia and
Mexico and all of these countries are on
the course of being then in 30 years
they will be half as wealthy as we what
does it look like to adjust in that
world to maintain the American virtues
not to fall prey to her own ism or not
abandon our virtues but at the same time
to recognize that people are part of a
shared whole of citizenship and that it
is unacceptable that you know democratic
political system that some people go
backwards while other people go forward
it is fine if people go forwards at
different rates but if some people go
backwards and other go forwards people
who are going backwards will vote to
stop the link backward and the more
leads ignore that the more they give
rise to the demand for classical
populism that will be the death of the
American regime yeah did you wait for
I'm sorries just they have the
microphones and they're taping stuff
thank you hopefully I don't hold it too
close but to what extent do you see
automation as complicating us being able
to find dignified work for the unskilled
it was a number of years ago President
Obama derided ATMs replacing bank
tellers but that's true and you know in
Seattle with the increase in the minimum
wage their pricing service workers out
of business writing I go to check out my
groceries and I checked I like to say
that the productivity consists primarily
of giving man a machine that's what
industrialization was was putting carbon
ace human labor behind you know
industrial machines that could multiply
their effort and that's what creates
productivity that's what's happening in
the third world is we're taking people
behind you know we're taking people from
behind yaks and sticking them in
factories and giving them rudimentary
machines if we have machines that can
work in and of themselves that produces
and even a greater issue clearly that
will produce great opportunity for the
people who build and fix and design the
machines what we need to do as a society
is treat the people who will might have
lesser opportunities with dignity and
that may mean that we move towards a
system of wage top off to preserve that
balance between staying head and private
entrepreneurship as opposed to a safety
net which rewards people only when they
give up i'm not sure what the solution
is but i think to close your eyes to the
possibility that we have new challenges
and that old ways are sufficient to meet
them is to build the demand for
classical populism left argument right
now is to ignore that challenge and to
force higher minimum wages which will
have effects that they don't want to
recognize but it is a legitimate attempt
to try and deal with this question I
think it's one that statesman needs who
would need to look at very seriously
what does the rise of intelligent
machines mean for the Liberal Democratic
wat Tyler Cowen in his book the average
is over presents a very stark angry and
I find entirely unattractive you which
is basically say this is the way life is
going to be deal with it he says it's
going to be less equal less fair and
there's nothing we can do about
right I mean that essentially what it
essentially means is that there is a
risk the more intelligent the machines
becoming we're not there yeah it's not
going to happen in our lifetime but the
risk is the more intelligent machines
become the less need people with
education and ability have of less
skilled people because they would have
slaves machine as so long as the
dystopic visions of machines becoming
self-aware launching Judgment Day and
all that stuff that dominates science
fiction on the movies today as long as
that doesn't come through you basically
get slaves so if you've got slaves what
do you do with the people who you used
to give money to in order to help you
live a better life that may be a
challenge for the next generation it's
not our challenge here our challenge
here is to manage the changes that we're
dealing with so that we maximize freedom
and comfort for people not just in our
country but also oversee but that is
something that then the next generation
may have to do it yes sir um before I
give you another chance to somebody else
have a question cuz we're running out of
time and I don't want to give somebody
else give you an extra question when
nobody else if this lady has a question
so if you don't mind I'll let her ask
given you wait for the microphone thank
you you mentioned um populism how many a
percentage in your estimate of the
American population understand it how
many percent understand it falling away
from understanding that our Americanism
system of government and I guess it's a
three-fold question and how much of the
threats I owe information operations is
succeeding in dumbing down the American
populace to where they can't even make a
educational and educated difference in
understanding even the for populous
positions um yeah what's what's the
percentage do you think primary guys
that understand our form of government I
what I tried to do was apply kind of you
know a taxonomic view the way I would
analyze things as a pellicle scientist
you know I don't think that anyone if
you went to trumpism if you went to a
trump rally instead do you understand
the four elements populism and how your
movement fits into it I think
number of people who would you know I
would be like wow wow I think there is a
very strong sense right now of a
disconnect between all segments of elite
society and American ideals and I think
that is something that is understood
that is very widespread in that what the
political order is trying to do is
groping towards a solution for that
issue but I think you know what the
people themselves understand main is not
going to be something that would be
expressed in a political science article
but is something that is very real which
is that the people who are the people
who are making decisions about my lives
don't know about my life and don't care
about my life and I'm going to do
something about that is it heart what
about you what the demand side of
populism ultimately they in America is
about I think they have enough
information to know I think I have to
cut it off now because it's about one
o'clock but thank you very much Thank
You Henry for a great talk I will just
quickly mention two things coming up on
November fifth Joseph Laconte with
King's College will be doing an evening
event on a hobbit a wardrobe and a Great
War talking about the relationship
between talking in CS lewis in the midst
of world war one our next AWC lecture is
William vogue Lee who's the senior
editor Thurman review of books will be
here on November twelfth talk about
liberalism conservatism in the run-up to
2016 thank you have great day